da brennen autos da brennen zwei autos
da oben ist ein crash in stadthagen
meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen hier zu einem spiel namens
gold mechanik was wir heute mal
zusammenzucken werden das heißt wir
drücken dir act of state
hier ist am start der playoff castor
rexe harry abbau 200 dollar das ist ein
punkt okay also das so wie es verstanden
hat das ziel des spiels ist es so viele
autos wie möglich zu beschädigen und ich
kann mir mit meinen 200 dollar jetzt die
sachen kaufen ist um stein vitor drei
steine geholt so gut wie nichts das
haben die nächst gekostet also ich kann
jetzt einen stein nehmen kann ihnen so
ziehen und dann lasse ich den jetzt hier
einfach mal dass ich dahin liegen dann
packe ich hier vorne noch ein hin und
dann packe ich hier noch allen hin und
jetzt kann ich einfach auf drop klicken
und ihr seht schon 0 euro steht hätte
was habe ich denn auch pech als ob ich
die steine einfach fallen lassen und da
einfach überhaupt nicht keiner geld also
diese kaputt gegangen weil die direkt
auf autos aufgefallen sind dass es
wieder das glück eines luca in so einem
spiel positioniert wie jetzt mal ein
bisschen anders drücke auf drop und wir
sehen schon als ob wieder so wenig für
als auf den stein und aber so lenders
wow 152 es ist auf jeden fall schon mal
ein richtiger highscore okay ich habe
jetzt mein letztes cash dafür aufgewandt
mir diese farbeimer zu holen
und noch ein ei und das werde ich jetzt
direkt rocken lassen und wenn ich jetzt
nicht mal endlich sonne 1501 dollar
witte war sverkos und blödmänner schafft
also ich bin ja das schaf vollidiot und
ihr seht ihr das da oben level programm
komm bitte von irgendwas einfach an zu
brennen sagt das eigentlich gar nicht
toll her okay 205 dollar geht eigentlich
klar
photoshop ist single of customers
betitelt ist tina fey broadway typen
gehört sondern seine autowerkstatt und
desto mehr autos wir kaputt machen desto
mehr kaputte autos kommen zu ihm und
desto mehr cash hat er machen
das ist so das spielprinzip wir sind
jetzt in level 2 which means we can bei
crazy ones und ich nehme dich mach das
jetzt einfach ich kann sogar vier dahin
packen alle dann können wir jetzt mal
richtig ich plötzlich eine katze der
honig hat sich hier so ein komischer und
hier dieses dings reifen es heißt
nagelbrett luca es heißt nagelbrett aber
wir drücken jetzt einfach mal auf drop
und gefallen schon runter was macht denn
die katze hat die katze überhaupt
irgendwas gemacht die in der mitte da
nicht sein als ob ich so viel nicht nur
kriege also daher weiß ich auch nicht so
der stein nichts kostet weil den kann
man dann einfach verwenden wenn du kein
cash mehr hast um wieder fit zu kriegen
das heißt es gibt quasi kein game over
in dem spiegel dieses spiel wurde
übrigens zugesendet von phil patrick
patrick wenn ihr auch denkt dass wir
irgendwelche coolen flashgames habt die
ihr mir senden könnte dann die eier
machen einfach nichts ich habe wieder
nahezu nichts kaputt gemacht und wieder
bekomme ich irgendwie 348 dollar
naja also wenn ihr irgendwelche
flashgames kennt die ich denn noch
machen könnte so kleine coole sachen
oder irgendwie so um den dreh
dann würde ich mich sehr freuen wenn ihr
mir die zu senden würde dann würde ich
die mal zog ihn in einem spiel und in
einem video und dann würde ich so gut
mache ich jetzt mal hier noch ein und da
kommt noch ein stein und jetzt weiß ich
dass gruppen und dann ist doch alles und
der steinburger ich glaube der
steinbring wirklich nur was wenn man den
komplett auf autos draufgesetzt
das ist nicht wahr haben schon wieder 0
cash bekomme jetzt kann ich mir nur die
steine kaufen oder oder wie ist das ist
komme ich manchmal hier ein experiment
die x
die drei steine hintereinander zusammen
mit dem 1 mal schauen ob da irgendwie
faktisch schild ist es einfach nahezu
nichts passiert wenn jetzt liga planen
ist einfach nur mit steinen zu hantieren
bis ich wieder richtig kescher und dann
mache ich mir mal richtig gedanken bei
einem level facto nichts passiert und
ich bekomme ganz genau null dollar das
kann doch nicht der ernst sein von
diesem spiel das ich einfach nichts auf
die kette kriege es ist schon wieder
verdammte kacke nicht passiert hier
magath ab ich warte und ich okay ich
hoffe ein board of nails dann noch ein
okay jetzt kann ich mir nur noch eier
und steine kaufen ich glaube irgendwie
die obere spur ist meine glücksspiel ich
weiß zwar nicht warum aber ich lasse es
jetzt einfach mal toppen und mein gott
der dem mörder mining 415 dollar alter
richtig leid jetzt kommt man wieder hier
eine katze zwei erklärte ok ich bleibe
an den stein das spiel macht irgendwie
echt relativ viel spaß und ich das mal
die katze hier fallen so gut das ist
jetzt nicht sonderlich viel passiert ein
neuer plan ist alles auf eine karte zu
setzen und ich nehme jetzt diese untere
spur
die hätten zu sammeln oder brennt ein
fahrzeug das ist richtig gut für meine
gesamtwertung glaube ich und wir sehen
schon ich bekomme 904 altern eis dann
kann ich mir jetzt den öl container das
und den der ball hat echt richtig gut
gefallen dann packen wir nochmal zwei
bälle drauf dann kommt da dieses ding in
dem wertpapiere das teil hin und einen
ball noch nach oben
dass das runterfallen und ich glaube das
wird somit die beste runde die wir jetzt
erreicht haben und wir sehen schon da
brennende autos da brennen zwei autos da
oben ist ein crash entstanden nur heißt
bo 1005pe wie navi am dritten level sind
das war mein einziges ziel dass wir
heute in street level kommen jetzt eine
komplett die level 2 alter medizin hier
die katze hinter diesen komischen öl
container das ding und hier einen
blumentopf und jetzt möchte ich noch
meine lieben freude dass das hier wieder
ein neuer und es sieht ganz nach einem
neuen highscore aus willich irgendein
auto vielleicht auch anfangen zu brennen
das wäre super wird dass ein neuer high
score wert ist nein das ist kein neues
geschäft nur 214 aber ich bin im neuen
level
okay ich habe jetzt eine granate einen
propangas tank gekauft und noch einen
steilen mein gott 85 nämlich noch ein
stein gut da lasse ich hier einfach mal
den steinen fallen da oben noch einen
stein hier dieses propangas jene
handgranaten in die handgranate wäre
vielleicht sinnvoll wenn ich hier in der
mitte einfach explodiert und ich weiß
nicht was die fünf im umkreis hat
naja ich lasse es einfach mal droppen
handgranate die haben kann dann einfach
nix gemacht da waren einfach keine autos
ok 9300 irgendwas habe ich dafür bekommt
noch nicht mal zwei handgranaten dann
noch hier dass ein nagelbrett dann noch
zwei eier dann packe ich hier noch eine
granate hin und hier dann haben wir
nämlich auf beiden spuren eventuell ist
es sogar sinnvoller wenn ich die herren
ranschmeißen oder irgendwie so
dann kommt hier ein noch hin hier noch
ein ei und da das nagelbrett und das ist
jetzt wirklich die letzte runde die ich
hier gerade mache weil ich nicht noch
hier die in kanada und wieder nichts
beide haben nicht hingekriegt okay ich
hab nur 360 jetzt insgesamt das heißt
ich möchte mich jetzt wieder
hocharbeiten mit anderen kleineren items
das war's mit lauten beständig der link
dazu in der beschreibung genau so wie
man twitter instagram widmen und ein
ganzes dorf wenn es euch gefallen hat
würde ich mich definitiv über eine
bewertung freuen und die beiden
abonnement falls ihm einen kernel und
dann sehen wir uns in einem anderen
video wieder übrigens habe dass das
video zu spät kam ich habe versprochen
dass heute zwei videos kam aber ich habe
es mir ja nicht geschafft liegen uni
schäden